こんにちははじめそうです皆さん最新作の劇場がポケットモンスター公庫
もう見られましたでしょ彼はザク島田
見ておりません
[音楽]
ana
誰だはっはっはっ行ってみたいんですよ見たいんですけどあの南聞いてくださいよ私
ここの予告編 youtube なんかってた映画の予告編
30秒が1分くらいのやつ見ただけでもあるんだかないちゃってね今回のテーマはその
親子の絆というかお父さんと息子家族の絆って言うなテーマなしってなんか俺もう余計
見ただけでその音楽とかで涙止まんなくなっちゃって
俺は松井なとこれたば俺本で見たらやばいなと思ってこの高ぶる肝臓全て出すために苔
特別に映画化を貸し切って一人でポケモンの映画見ていきたいとおもいます
もう僕は周りの人を気にしなくていいですもうここを見ただけでは感情と気持ちをもう
周りを気にせずどんどん喋っ
喋っちゃ駄目ですねが中はでもまあ一人てるから言って
でしょう誰もいないからもう迷惑とか考えずに宝庫見て行きたいと思います本当の映画
館ってこういうことしちゃダメなんですけどねとクイズの許可を得てやらせていただい
ております中で早速 a 方を貸し切ってポケモンないが見ていきたいとおもいます
では行こうよっ
オレが持ってるよ
ua な鎧のことだ鎧のことだ
プーラーしだ
ら運営管理節減だ roots なーるギャンくらうんだわー
5位すごい
あきたんじゃないこれもう
ん
きたねうは重なるん
[音楽]
rin
わー
まあやばいいいいい
どうしたのん
ちょっと減っていった
あれはオール我々は研究材料
気を付けくださいないわー
インドメーカー寂しさは分かるぞ
じゃないアハ脳に入れてよ
[音楽]
家のりーの
余裕のはこっちの声だよっ
[音楽]
はぁ
家になるって言うのは
ってことだったん
1分
me
[音楽]
tee
cue
[音楽]
いいと思ってる
ものに
[音楽]
よかったーー
というわけでポケともさあここを見ました誰のピカチュウもありがとう来てくれて
父ちゃんよく頑張ったね
猫背だね部屋強すごい外だったねほんとに何でしょすごい
親子の絆をや声にフューチャーしたポケモンの映画だったかなと思います僕結構毎回
ポケモン映画見てるんですけど今は全くなくてすごい
誰でも見れるというか小さい子どもからお父さんとかいろんな年齢の人が楽しめる
分かりやすい映画だと思いました
いやーちょっとはずが
だから23海外ちょっと感情が高ぶるシーンが上がってとても私は感動します
ヘッドにある映画情報サイトとかなんですけどすごいこういう問題が評価が高いだ
シーンで僕だけってでもちょっと本当はどうなんと思うといると思うんだけどもみんな
が良いと言っております何だろうともちゃんの声優さん
父ちゃんザレイドの声がすごい大事だと思うんですけども中村勘九郎さんの声が本当に
めちゃくちゃ
父ちゃんですげーな声優さんの声にもだいぶ
しびれましたそしてですね劇場に来た方にはなんかこっちら
受け方がとーちゃんざるうどんが色々とことかであるんでそちらが手に入るらしいので
ぜひ入れてみてください主題歌も良かったし水もきれいだったしなぞのポケモンのこと
があって実には分かんないんですよ疑問世界となんかポケモンのゲーム
人間のゲームのそのスイッチの旬ちょっとうまく説明できないんですけどもとりあえず
見たらわかることがたくさんありますのでぜひ見てくださいなんですけども
既存に行く際は是非感染症の要望をしっかりマスクとかして来てください
あーお父さんの人とか絶対みてくださいばいばーい
[音楽]
あっはっは